buffalo says someday we're going to get
paired i can finally play my 52 move
prep
i'm excited to see it
murphy that bad
oh yeah
i could murphy that bed sometimes i do
sometimes if i feel like it's too
crowded in here then i'll open it up the
room opens up it's very nice
yo waxer from leech us good morning dude
good morning hope you're having a good
morning
all right go for the nice
whatever this is
oh
yeah he's gonna do a stonewall so
yeah classic
uh queen's indian defense versus
stonewall
i'll go 94.
i had a i had a very very exciting
queen's ending defense versus the
stonewall
when was it
last
thursday three days ago it was very
exciting
okay so now
now we can play we can copy him
we can do the copy
and it's okay before we didn't really
want to play f5 because knight e5
maybe was going to give us some problems
but this should be okay now
so yeah for those of you who saw the
video on thursday that is going to be
going on the youtube channel
probably
[Music]
uh
probably next week maybe this week
probably next week
i might bring this
guy to f6
okay he
he hops his knight in
so i have to either take this or play
knight df6
and i should probably take it
if i don't then i might run into some
problems along this diagonal so i'll
take
it takes for the f pawn
probably take oh jeez i just i blundered
bishop b5 there
um
queen a4 is less effective because i
have queen d7
so yeah he's definitely let me back in
this i think we definitely blundered
there for a moment
yeah this should be good he's got the
terrible terrible bishop the queen trait
has to be a mistake
um
if not queen takes d7 then queen a4
definitely one of those two moves were a
mistake i think
um
and yeah what's the deal here
bishop a6
this move just looks fantastic
looks pretty bad for my bishop but
looks even worse for his knight
where are his pieces going is that okay
is that an okay plan to make
yeah i think it should be
should be okay
oh
maybe i'm just i'm
i think i'm silly
i think i'm super super super duper
silly
i think that is this the case
maybe maybe have blundered back
b3 we go b5 this is all expected
okay that has to be a mistake because
now i can go a5
open up this line
and there's no a3
so i'm either getting a past
juicer
which is going to go push push
push push push
or
yeah
this is good too
well i can just take this straight away
and pushing is also pretty good
i don't yeah i should start by taking
[Music]
his pieces are just so cramped
and
too undeveloped
too undeveloped
i think this is
possibly the best move
for him
bouvon 655 i am bored
you should do something about that
you should definitely
should definitely definitely do
something about that
well this guy is still pinned so i mean
we don't really need to
don't really need to do anything
yeah we'll just
we'll just keep restricting the pieces
all of the pieces are trapped the
bishop's trapped
the knights trapped
the rook is trapped
like dang yo all of the pieces are
trapped
is that still the case i think it is
i think it is
bishop b3
rexella from leches asks hey harrison
what are your thoughts about chess
olympiad happening in india
um
yeah it's good
i think it's good for chess
more chess tournaments
i don't really have any strong opinions
on it or anything so
uh yeah i mean it should be good
all right
and just play g6 here
keep things clamped down
go for that move
probably h6 is good
yeah his
all his king side or all his queenside
pieces are just
totally
totally shut down
[Music]
i don't know if i want to do this
feels good
but
i'm not sure about what happens after
rook g2
so i'm just gonna start with rook c8
because i mean this just looks this
looks insane and and by insane i mean
insanely good
guys pieces are in jail
what a game my pieces my opponent's
pieces are in jail
what can he do here you can't do
anything
here the knight comes out
what's the play
how can i make progress
i can't really trade into opposite
colored bishops that seems like it's
going backwards
well now i can back up with this bishop
now that my pawn is defended so that
seems like a good a good starting point
yo gory asked how'd my day go dude it
went really well thanks for asking
all right sweet
let's uh let's push this guy
hmm
takes
sure
um
i go here first
that looks pretty good yeah
looks pretty good
looks like i'm going to be winning
[Music]
a piece here
whoo baby
clean them up
good game mike angelo
some would read it as michelangelo but
it's
mick or maybe it's mick angelo i'm not
sure but however you pronounce your name
very good game sorry your pieces had to
go to jail